The first real solution to this problem,
and one that is frequently still used today,
is called Diffie-Hellman Key Exchange.
It was first published by Whitfield Diffie and Martin Hellman
in a very famous 1976 paper.
It was actually discovered a few years earlier than that
by Malcolm Williamson, who was working at the
British government communication headquarters.
This is the successor to Bletchley Park.
It was kept classified, so Williamson didn't get credit for this,
and it wasn't known that it had been discovered earlier there until quite recently.
And this idea came from a paper that Diffie and Hellman published in 1976.
I mentioned Shannon's paper as one of the 3 most important papers in cryptography.
This is one of the other 3.
The third one--and I'm not trying to put these 3 in order, just chronologically--
is the RSA paper that we'll talk about a little later.
But this paper really introduced the idea of public-key cryptography.
It didn't provide a solution.
It provided a solution to part of the problem.
They started with this introduction about we're on the brink
of a revolution in cryptography and posed the question of
can we build cryptographic tools that are the equivalent
to a written signature?
There are lots of other kinds of applications
they talked about in the paper as well as the idea of
basing crypto systems on known hard problems
or believed to be hard problems.
The one solution that is in the paper that we're going to talk about today
is this Diffie-Hellman key exchange protocol,
and it's actually quite a simple protocol.
It's still very widely used, and it allows 2 parties
without any prior agreement to be able to establish a shared secret key.